this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello minimizers welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists do you ever treat
yourself poorly with negative self-talk
self-doubt and even self-hatred are the
stories you tell yourself making you
miserable well perhaps there's a
holistic approach to change your
attitude mindset and behavior maybe
there's a simple way to love and
encourage the most important person in
your life
you
that's what we're going to explore today
we're here with the author of the new
book the high five habit mel robbins is
here no thanks for joining us whoa
whoa you know what i just realized
what's that this is so perfect for you
guys yeah because what we're going to
learn to live uh with
the the stuff we're going to have less
of when we're done talking and you
implement this is you're going to have
less self-doubt you're going to have
less self-criticism you're gonna have
less mental emotional physical
physiological baggage that you are
dragging around we are gonna throw that
crap in the trash hit delete and leave
you feeling lighter we're to prove to
you using science that we can hit the
reset button on your mind and get rid of
that garbage you're dragging around and
let's go like i'm so i didn't like here
we go heck yeah well you know when i saw
the title of the book it's it's the high
five habit by the way holding up here
for the camera um i was like oh this is
certainly a metaphor for something
before i started diving into it and i'm
like no she's actually talking about
like getting into a habit of high-fiving
yourself
and you know if you were to just if you
were to just tell me that i would kind
of be skeptical but like you said like
there's science behind it that i can't
wait to get into we're gonna dive into
the book on this minimal part we're
gonna talk about self-doubt on the
maximal we're gonna dive deep into the
book also several ways to deal with
self-hatred now mel this is a listener
driven show so i thought we would start
with a
question from one of our patreon
supporters supporters frederico from
patreon has a question for us
how do i rebuild my relationship with
myself when starting from ground zero
so
mel this is a pretty broad expansive
question and so i thought maybe we would
talk about this and then we would narrow
down into specifically what were we
talking about so starting from ground
zero might mean hey i had a traumatic
event happen to me or maybe my life is
changing maybe i'm reaching a point in
my life where i need to do something
different i'm learning that everything
i've done to make me happy or fulfilled
or satisfied isn't working so for
frederico where do we even start what do
we talk about uh you actually start the
exact same place we all have to start
every morning in the mirror
every single morning in the mirror you
see the most important relationship that
you have in life is the one you have
with yourself
it is the foundation of every
relationship that you have it's the
foundation of how you experience life
and what we are going to punch a hole
through today
is the fact that every single human
being has a disgusting ugly
self-destructive habit that nobody is
talking about that is part of your
morning routine
yeah and here's the habit
frederico and everybody on the planet
currently stands in front of the mirror
as they brush their teeth hopefully
you're brushing your teeth and wiping
that gunk out of your mouth right so we
get rid of the dragon breath
but as you're doing that
you're doing one of two things every
human being does this
you either beat the daylights out of
yourself
and you focus on all the stuff you need
to fix
the things you hate
the parts of yourself you can't stand
and that's the good news
because the majority of people
are doing the other thing
this is sad the majority of people
cannot even look at themselves in the
mirror
because they are disgusted
or they are disappointed or they don't
like how
long they've let themselves go
and so every morning
part of your morning routine right now
and this is this goes so down to the
core of what's not working and what you
can easily flip and change
because if you stand in front of the
mirror and you can't even look at
yourself that is a habit of self
rejection
that gets repeated every single day you
are not even secure enough with yourself
and accepting enough of yourself
to look at the mirror and see holy cow
because here's the other thing i want
everyone to understand right now we're
going to explain the high five habit but
here's the first breakthrough
a
you're either be honest with yourself
which do you do do you not look in the
mirror or do you focus on the things
that you need to fix yeah no i i mean i
do look in the mirror and yeah there's
certainly i'm going through the day i'm
like thinking i could have done things
differently what i need to do the next
day yeah so i do look in the mirror okay
yeah i i tend to avoid looking in the
mirror
yeah why is that you tell me yeah i
don't know
well think about it why do you think you
don't look in the mirror i i've never
thought that it was a necessity uh to to
gaze upon myself to
i mean i'm sure i glance
there's a picture of me in the mirror
but it becomes second nature in a way
yes and so i don't beat myself up so so
i mean that's a different that's a
different sort of story that we tell
ourselves but i've never thought about
the power of looking in the mirror and
how that might actually benefit me well
i want you to consider it's not a
reflection
there are
two human beings in the bathroom with
you every morning
there's you uh-huh and my daughter she's
always yeah so now there's four
bothering me
or the dog or whatever yeah
uh or there's so there's two human
beings right there's you
and there's a human being in the mirror
and
the human being in the mirror is really
trying
and they are
in need of your support
and they are in need of your
encouragement
and they need you to wake up and to see
them and they need you to stop beating
them up and they need some encouragement
and this is a really deep thing
and it begins every morning by simply
taking a moment
and being with the human being in the
mirror which i think represents your
soul your spirit your potential
for people that you know kind of like
the inner child work and that stuff it
represents the person inside you that's
still trying to heal
and if you begin your day every day by
not looking in the mirror
or by picking apart the things you don't
like 91 percent of women do not like how
they look
wow 50 of people
cannot look in the mirror
and what you just said is is exactly
right most of us it's so casual spend
that moment
drifting into the day where we start to
think about all the things we need to do
or you know if you're like a lot of us
you're already pile driving yourself
going i got up too late and i got to
answer that email and i didn't get this
done
and then you catch yourself in the
mirror
and you then start oh my god i look like
crap and i got to be on a zoom call in
eight minutes and i haven't walked the
dog yet and the pile driving begins yeah
and you guys know that once your
attitude goes negative it's going to
continue to take you down yeah and so
first things first we got to break the
habit of self-rejection
and we need to create a new habit
of partnership trust encouragement
compassion connection to self
because if we can start to help you
every morning to start your day
with a little bit of partnership and
compassion with yourself
if you can build the ability to like
yourself even if you're not where you
want to be in life
it won't matter if other people don't
like you because that can't change the
fact that you like yourself
yeah and so this isn't about being a
narcissistic [ __ ] this is not about
being a jerk this is not about being
selfish this is not about being some
cocky overconfident this is about
compassion
this is about support
this is about your most
fundamental profound needs love people
use things that's your book
none of us know how to love ourselves
and it begins every morning with this
new habit i want you to create that i
created during a terrible moment in my
life called the high five habit well
let's talk about that moment what what
what's the moment that led you to the
high five habit okay so um it was april
2020 when i stumbled into this thing and
my brand of life improvement basically
involves either falling into a hole or
digging one for myself and then
realizing after uh either trying to
drink my problems away or screaming at
my husband or avoiding them that i need
to somehow build a ladder emotionally to
crawl my way out of it and so i did not
set out to go okay we're gonna like
write a book it's gonna have a five in
it because i wrote the five second rule
that's not what happened right what
happened is in march on march 10th of uh
2020
i had my dream job i was a daytime
syndicated talk show host right and we
were at cbs broadcast center i'm 51
years old my dreams come true they walk
into the studio and they say we found
covet in the building you have five
minutes
to evacuate
and just like that i was fired from my
dream job
and i of course did the anti-minimalist
thing and i raced upstairs to my
dressing room and grabbed every single
thing that was not nailed down and
shoved it into a garbage bag and dragged
it down the hallway right literally
stealing it and so i'm like i'm taking
this stuff i have no idea what i'm
coming back
and so
um
i i and i get home and i think we all
had that moment
if it wasn't during the pandemic you've
had that moment in your life that i say
draws a line in the sand there's a
before and after
whether it's somebody saying i don't
love you anymore or breaking your back
or deciding montana's for me there are
moments in your life good and bad where
there's a line in the sand and you know
that things will never be the same again
that's right yeah so describe a moment
like that for yourself that was negative
yeah yeah well
most people listen to know the story my
mom died my marriage ended both in the
same month and it was like getting into
two car crashes one car crash led to the
other one in a way it smacked me in
there and from that moment i didn't know
what was going to be different
but i knew that things weren't ever
going to go back to whatever was in the
rear view yeah excellent yeah
oh man for me it made me think of uh
i was very addicted to pain pills at a
certain point
and
when you go without um the opioids you
get a withdrawal that i would not wish
on my worst enemy
and uh i couldn't get my pills
and like across my mind where i was like
well i could just do heroin like
everyone's like if i snort it like
that's okay yeah as long as i'm not
shooting it i'm not an addict right
exactly and i just remember like that
was
this moment of like oh [ __ ] i need help
like and nothing was ever was the same
ever since yeah yeah well this was that
for me because i had for people that
know my story i'd spent the last 10
years
literally reinventing myself we were 800
grand in debt and i was unemployed in
2008 as my husband's restaurant business
was going under and i invented the
five-second rule to get myself out of
bed because the anxiety was so crushing
and i
literally clawed my way out of that hole
and it was like dragging a cruise ship
through a parking lot to try to change
our life right every day small decisions
five four three two one five four three
two one five four three two one
and so
fast forward 12 years i've completely
changed who i am i've
reinvented my life i've built a business
i've paid off the debt and so as i lose
this job i have this weird feeling where
i'm like what the heck this is how this
goes yeah
i'm like a nice person now like i you
know have changed this is what you're
doing to me universe god like whatever
you believe in
come on and then the publisher that was
publishing a different book canceled the
contract
and said we want the money back oh wow
well i hadn't written the book so they
were entitled to do that that was a
smart decision on their point and
thankfully that was not the book i was
meant to write
and so i had to figure out how to get
money back then every speech starts to
cancel the ppp loans aren't there yet
now i'm wondering how am i going to pay
my bills how am i going to pay my teams
my kids come home like our house is a
tsunami of grief anger we've got three
kids two whose college experience has
just imploded
so by three weeks in
i'm literally have not changed out of my
pajamas in several weeks wow
i am eating breakfast for dinner mm-hmm
the dog is letting himself out we as a
family are on the couch just mainlining
glee
and i wake up one morning
and i feel the weight of the world on my
shoulders and everybody's had this
feeling this is why the high five habit
is exploding it is exactly what was
supposed to hit the world right now
everybody feels depleted
punched in the face
uncertain low energy yeah that's exactly
how i was waking up
and so i on the morning that i that i
invented this high five habit
i woke up i felt the pin of anxiety i
know better than to lay there so i go
five four three two one use the five
second rule i get out of bed i make my
bed so i don't climb back into it yeah i
then walk to the bathroom as i'm
standing in the bathroom i'm doing this
disgusting habit we just talked about
i'm in my underwear
don't even have a brawn haven't had a
cup of coffee yet and i'm brushing my
teeth and i'm already thinking like you
said about all the things i need to do
yeah i gotta call the kids therapist i
gotta figure out this i gotta how am i
gonna pay the bill
and all of a sudden i catch a glimpse of
myself and i go
oh my god
you look like hell
um
gray hair coming in dark circles under
my eyes i got this waddle on my neck
when boobs hanging lower than the other
and then of course as i'm beating the
hell out of myself i now start to think
how am i going to get done today like i
i didn't answer the text i haven't
walked the dog how am i going to get
ready in it like now i'm just
pound yeah now if either one of you had
walked into the room
first of all you would have been
horrified but secondly
i would have been able to spin on a dime
i would have been able to turn and be
like uh you got this you guys have been
so successful you have reinvented
yourself so many times do you know who
you are do you know that your
documentary is on netflix in 90
countries do you know have you forgot
like i would have been able to lift you
up and kick you right out of that thing
no problem but you were having trouble
doing that for yourself because of the
stories that you were manufacturing in
your mind
thousand percent and also even if i had
said
some stupid pep talk
i wouldn't have believed it yeah this is
why most mantras by the way don't work
for people because you pick something
you don't believe
the stories that you have been telling
yourself are so plowed into your mind
that your mind's like yep nope you don't
think you're awesome i got 20 years of
you telling me otherwise yeah
yeah that mantras don't work you have to
pick a pathetic mantra we'll get into
that in a little bit but so i'm standing
there
my attitude's going into the tank
i have no idea i think it was the
universe literally i think the universe
was like the world needs this now and
this crazy lady is the one to do it
boom and so i
see myself in the mirror and let's go
back to is it
rico yeah
i see myself in the mirror i put my
toothbrush down
and for whatever reason i find myself
raising my hand as pathetic as it sounds
to my own reflection because the woman
in the near mirror looked like she
needed it
[Music]
and here's the thing first of all
it's not like lightning shot through the
ceiling and struck me okay it's not like
the heavens open and the angels sang in
that moment
but something shifted and we're going to
talk about the science of what you're
going to feel shift inside you because
the coolest thing about the high five
habit is it's actually taking
programming in your nervous system and
your brain
and physiologically that's already
programmed in you yes and it's aiming it
back at you
it's the coolest freaking thing in the
world
i want to talk to you about that i also
want to talk about where self-doubt
comes from okay let's uh let's get to a
question here from mark in perth
australia i've read all your books and
listened to almost all your podcasts i
can't find much information on your
broken marriages
unfortunately me and my wife separated
early this year as we were going in
different directions
and our values were also differing
how did you guys both bounce back from
your broken marriages and also manage
the guilt
talk about a template for
self-doubt inner conflict
looking in the rear view and pointing
out every single thing that went wrong
mark i'm so sorry that you're going
through this and i understand the pain
because ryan and i have certainly both
been through this
and and the the pain that is there also
starts to cloud the past in a way it
starts making up stories that didn't
necessarily exist or amplifying these
tiny little stories now can we talk
about this hell yes
this is it right here
what mark is going through is it
because when you stand in the bathroom
before yourself and i said there are two
people in the bathroom
there's you mark the guy going through
the divorce with all of the regret and
the shame and the beating up and
everything that he's experiencing in
real time which is normal
and there's a human being in the mirror
who's also experiencing it
yes who needs your partnership
and so
when
mark stands in front of the mirror mark
after you listen i actually want you to
go right to your bathroom right now i
want you to stand in front of your
mirror and i want you to take a minute
and just look at yourself look past your
face
look past your body i want you to see if
you can see
the energy the spirit the soul the the
humanity
in the person in the mirror
and what you're going to experience is i
tell you now i want you
feeling everything that you feel regret
shame sadness fear uncertainty all of it
not suppressing it oh god no and i don't
want you to say a thing
because mantras don't work uh-huh i'm
into that i want you to just raise your
hand in silence and high-five yourself
now what's gonna happen is
one of two things one of two things
happens we've now been researching this
for a year we have a hundred thousand
people at this moment from 90 countries
doing a five day challenge it is
incredible and there are only two things
that people experience when you do the
high five habit for the first time first
of all you're going to stand there and
everybody has this feeling like am i
really doing a high five in the mirror
like this is kind of stupid like
well the reason why we all have that
feeling is because we are breaking the
opposite habit
so your brain currently rejects you a
high five let's talk about a high five
and what it represents when either one
of you have high-fived somebody else or
you've received one
what does the high-five communicate joy
celebration what else um
encouragement motivation
uh inspiration acceptance yeah yeah like
you've never high-fived somebody and
went i hate you you suck
i hope you lose
even when a teammate blows a shot if you
high-five them you're like uh shake it
off man i still believe in you yes what
are you getting yeah oh no it just makes
me think of a boss we used to have who
would always go to people like to high
five them and then he'd pull it away
what a dick i know he was such a dick
but it was but it was like but it's
amazing though like just it's the exact
opposite uh because he was he was uh
holding back that high five correct like
he's getting someone excited for and
he's like psych
i'm not gonna high five you loser yeah
that's exactly what that says yeah but
so when you actually have done a high
five or received one you have gotten a
boost to dopamine
your nervous system gets the energy of
celebration
jolted through it
physiologically you change
it's why it feels so good
and so your brain doesn't know the
difference between high-fiving somebody
else and actually high-fiving yourself
because it's been an action that's been
repeated for so long
this is a field of study called
neurobics
so all of the goodness that comes from
high-fiving somebody else the positive
programming i believe in you i see you i
love you shake it off i still got you
i'm encouraging you
we're doing this we can still win
it's okay
this is hard but okay
all of that positive programming is in
your basal ganglia and is attached to
the physical motion of a high five i
love it the second mark stands in front
of the mirror to practice the high five
habit
and he feels weird that's okay that
means you're about to practice new
behavior and you go to raise your hand
you can in the moment you start be
thinking i hate my life i [ __ ] things up
i wish i could change things but as you
start to extend your arm your brain
recognizes the gesture and shuts that
stuff down
because neurologically you cannot think
something negative
the programming's already in there this
is the coolest thing in the world you
don't have to say a thing and so the
high five isn't like yeah i'm getting
divorced that's not what it is it's holy
cow this is hard
and i still love you and i'm still going
to be here with you i see you i see you
yeah and we're going to get through this
together yes it's going to be okay
that's what the high five says in that
moment and most people resist so you're
either going to have a super positive
reaction so uh the positive reaction
comes in two forms you either crack a
big smile or you laugh that's the
dopamine flooding your brain or you
start sobbing
and the sobbing is a sign it's a release
it's this partnership and connection to
yourself at a crazy deep level
that you've been yearning for for
decades yes and it feels so
good
but the more common thing and this is
what mark is probably going to feel is
resistance and the resistance is all of
the baggage that we want to delete from
your life so when you stand before
yourself in the mirror
you drag we minimalist hate this you
drag a freight train semi truck load
full of crap from your past
if you let's get talk about the
categories that this falls into because
there are three i've researched the heck
out of this like bring it on i can
literally
go for hours about the power of this i
am so excited not because it's worked
for me but because i am standing
shoulder to shoulder with hundreds of
thousands of people around the world and
the world's leading researchers saying
this not only works it is groundbreaking
and because it's the how
for forgiveness
it's the how for self-love it is the how
for self-empowerment
it's incredible and so um as mark stands
there and as you stand there and if you
start to feel this resistance the first
category of resistance is things that
have been done to you
so if you've experienced trauma
addiction abuse abandonment neglect
heartache terrible accidents all of
stuff that you're not responsible for
a lot of people drag that cargo load
full and park it between themselves and
the person in the mirror
and they see all of that and say the
person i see does not deserve a high
five because they're unworthy or damaged
or unlovable because of that
yeah what are you getting i see you
smiling ear to ear yeah no i
you know it's funny you brought up the
the narcissism earlier and i think one
of the reasons i the the reasons i
actually look in the mirror is i am
going to check my hair how's my hair
today right and so there isn't is there
isn't a seeing of the other person in
fact i've always i've always identified
with you know the musician moby he
removed all the mirrors from his house
sort of thing and what i appreciated
about that is he was trying to remove
the vanity from from his life and maybe
there was a point where that was
necessary for him but also at the same
time what you might be removing
is that seeing of your
self yeah
mark i'm gonna send you a copy of mel's
book it's called the high five habit
also you asked about ryan's and my
failed marriages failed in quotes
because i wouldn't look at him that way
there's we graduated from some marriages
yeah at one point and we wrote about
that and love people use things so i'm
gonna send you a copy of that as well
because we talk about in there about
infidelity from both of us but also the
things the marriage was over way before
the marriage was over
and we we write about sort of what
happened and love people use things so
we're gonna send you a copy of both of
those books mark ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lending round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions or comments to 937-202-4654
yes indeed now mel during the lightning
round this is where ryan and i and our
guests we do our best to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response okay
we call them minimal maxims and podcast
sean edits them puts the right commas
and semicolons in and makes it look
beautiful for the show notes he has a
pocket full of em dashes as well he's
he's an em dash connoisseur you can find
all those in the show notes also over at
minimal minimalmaxims.com thanks to our
good friend jessica she puts them over
there now really what we do is we
monitor on a bit we get a question
we'll we'll just talk about it and then
we'll tweeze out something that's
tweetable we have a question here from
caden
can thinking negatively about yourself
actually benefit your life in a positive
way
um
can thinking negatively benefit you
positively i i reject the premise of the
question
um
the the negative thinking versus the
positive thinking
these are mantras in a way right and we
often tell i just need to think more
positively and if i say the right things
in the right order and do the 17
different steps then i will be happy
now this question's a little bit
different it's
are negative thoughts positive for me
based on the research
yes
two forms of guilt okay there's
destructive and productive
productive guilt is guilt that motivates
you to change
i miss my brother's birthday again damn
it
i feel bad about that i feel guilty
about that so i am going to put it in my
calendar on repeat yes a week before
that guilt motivated me to change but
dwelling on it oh my god becomes the
problem and i hesitate like you to even
say that yes it can because the majority
of the 50 to 80 000 thoughts that you
have today experts basically have pegged
it between 80 to 90 percent are negative
and so i don't think there is any
benefit to
talking negatively to yourself to
beating yourself up to being hard on
yourself the research actually shows
that it's demotivating and demoralizing
yeah
yeah well even when you you you know
have that
that thought it's a negative thought
that creates some positive action so
it's really the positive action
that you're because you're recognizing
the symptom and you're like oh i have to
do something to avoid this in the future
but still
like i also want to say like you can't
think your way out of a bad situation
right you cannot you it thinking is not
going to do much for you if you're in a
bad state well you know what else i just
realized in the example that i gave is
that i had already teased apart
the thing that i did for my self-worth
yeah so the mistake that most people
make is they say i missed my brother's
birthday i'm a bad person therefore i'm
the type of person who is habitually
late or wrong or bad or negative correct
so here's here's a pithy answer for you
maybe we can unpack it a little bit you
would break up with anyone who treats
you as poorly as you treat yourself
and and that person wouldn't be your
friend they wouldn't be your lover they
wouldn't be your spouse if my wife
treated me the way that i treat me
we'd have some serious problems right i
don't know about that
i think most people
actually uh are in relationships that
reflect how they feel about themselves
again your most powerful relationship is
the one you have with the person in the
mirror right if you can't look at
yourself and even though you don't have
a million dollars in the bank or you're
40 pounds overweight or you're not where
you thought you were if you can't look
at yourself and still see a human being
that deserves support and that deserves
love and is still trying you will step
out of the world out into the world and
you will seek that validation from
everybody else and you also won't let
people fully love you because if you
can't love yourself you'll start to
think how could they possibly love me so
i actually don't agree with that i think
i think that your friends do treat you
well but if you want to go might treat
you better than you probably do but
that's just to your face yeah and i also
feel that it does come back to how you
feel about yourself
it's interesting because like when i
talk to myself in a negative light i
mean yeah i would not if anyone talk to
me the way that i talk to myself you
have an idiot what the heck is your
problem you're such a [ __ ] if anyone
talk to me like that i i i see what
you're saying milburn like i would
totally look at them and be like in what
world do you think it's okay
to voice these things to me like that
yeah but it's okay for me to do it to
myself yeah i don't yeah it's crazy i
also think we underestimate
how people have been spoken to growing
up
and how their
family dynamics and family systems
operate
with the smackdowns and the passive
aggressive
and the
uh kind of like boundary needing
behavior
that has become so casual
that we just kind of tolerate it because
it was done to our parents so they do it
to us and now we do it back to them
and i'm here to say the high five in the
mirror
by
reestablishing and rebuilding
a really powerful compassionate
supportive relationship with yourself
it will change every relationship that
you have because when you start to treat
yourself with respect you will not
accept disrespect from other people
absolutely yeah well it's interesting
that's tweetable you can tweet that
podcast sean yeah heck yeah well it just
makes me think about how like my buddy
sent me this um
youtube video
of like this guy kind of like just
criticizing our last documentary and i
like i was just kind of watching it and
now you know the guy's entitled to his
opinion and i didn't really watch the
whole thing through just kind of looked
at the highlights
and then i ran into him later um was
over at his house and he was like yeah
man he's like how do you get through
when someone like
you know criticizing he's like i don't
know i don't know if i could put up with
that if i was in your position i'm like
dude
i really love who i see in the mirror
and i'm doing my best man
like that person is entitled to his
opinion and that's all it is it's an
opinion but if i didn't like the the man
that i saw in the mirror
i would project all of the negative
emotions incorrect he misunderstands me
and no you're wrong because of this but
i i can really separate that um yeah the
criticism from the the anger that you
know 10 years ago i probably would have
had well what's interesting is that
people that
spend a lot of time gossiping
or criticizing
do that to themselves oh yeah yeah
that's a good point so you got like i
look at anybody that sits in their
parents basement and fires off comments
with extreme sadness and empathy i'm
like wow
what is your life like that you actually
turned on a camera and needed attention
by just pounding our documentary into
the sand wow poor guy
who hurt you so badly yeah imagine if
you put that same energy into actually
creating something you care about yeah
oh and well it's it's this guy makes a
living from criticizing i'm sure but
there are professional critics too and
so the counter argument to that is there
are some people who do add to the
conversation just because someone you
don't have to like our documentary
either right and so once the thing the
thing has been created it's no longer up
for me to determine because i can't base
my happiness my joy my satisfaction
on
the opinions of everyone well let me let
me come back to the high five habit
because this is relevant we talked about
one piece of baggage all the stuff that
was done to you mark is facing the
baggage that's the second piece mark our
our person who is getting the divorce
because the other thing you bring into
the bathroom is you bring in all the
things you've done that you regret
the addiction the lying the cheating the
squandering of opportunity the hurting
yourself the hurting of other people all
[ __ ] you just did while you were trying
to survive yeah
and then stuff that you would forgive
mel robbins or either one of you two for
but when you stand in front of yourself
like mark's gonna stand in front of
himself he will judge all the things he
wishes he had done differently
and he's gonna see a person that doesn't
deserve a high five right now because of
those things and i'm here to tell you if
you actually want to graduate from this
marriage if you want to heal and learn
you have to raise your hand for where
you are
and say despite all of that
i'm going to still be here supporting
you and you still deserve to do better
and then when we're talking about this
piece about self-criticism and judgment
again everybody has a habit of
self-rejection in some form
and so
one of the reasons why we have it is as
youngsters we got a lot of positive
praise
for achieving that's right right you
know you get a good grade you do great
in the snowboarding competition you you
know play great in the band everybody's
cheering it feels good you get a
dopamine release and so now we've become
these adults that are addicted to
external validation yeah pleasure
seeking yes you want you but and and
again we are subject and and victims of
this
looking for likes you think if you don't
drive a range rover have a million
dollars or your hair is not kinky or
this that and the other thing that until
you have those things until you lose the
weight until you launch the podcast
until you do the things that you're
supposed to be doing you don't deserve a
high five if i didn't go to the gym
today why would i high-five myself i'll
tell you why you're [ __ ] breathing
we celebrate your birthday why why do we
celebrate birthdays uh just uh yeah to
celebrate the life that yeah that we
were born yeah yes and for most of us
because self-doubt and the stories you
talked about this in the open
are so relentless and so relentlessly
negative
you have no idea
all of the things you're doing so well
you have no idea all of the little
things that you do you got out of bed
you fed the dog you got to work you
smiled at somebody you sent three emails
in my book that makes you
deserving of a high five by the way you
don't have to do
anything to be deserving of celebrating
it's not about the doing
it's about the being correct you need
this like we are looking to everybody
else our bosses our friends our spouses
our partners everybody so give us our
most fundamental need do you see me yeah
do you love me
do you support me
that's what we all want and i'm here to
tell you if you start every day by
simply demonstrating
to yourself by high-fiving yourself in
the mirror and you let all of that
programming and the dopamine and the
jolt of celebratory circuitry work in
your nervous system you affirm your most
foundational needs and this is not just
mel robbins making this up there chapter
two is packed with research there are
ten pages of citations in the back of
this book on all the studies yeah that
have been done i love it ryan you got
something pithy for us yeah my pithy
answer is this self-love extinguishes
the flame of self-hate
so that's really the answer i mean yeah
you might be able to take a negative
emotion and and react from that and do
something different but really like the
the answer is self-love not
self-criticism yeah
flip that around it's if
kaden was asking if i hate myself more
will i eventually love myself more
obviously we know the answer obviously
we got a bunch more to talk about but
first emma you got something for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners hi my name
is kathleen and i'm from nashville
tennessee i'm calling to respond to
episode 52 on stress i have two tips for
tasha the teacher i am also a teacher i
teach a writing class for 11th and 12th
graders and grading papers is always
very time consuming i'm not convinced
that there's a way around that even
though i've been trying for
years now i have discovered that with
writing my students learn a lot more
when they edit and correct their work
so i'd like to suggest that tasha have
students grade their own papers
you shouldn't do this with every paper
but you can easily set up a system where
students grade their own papers
every now and then you can write a
worksheet that asks them to identify key
parts of their paper like topic
sentences and supporting points and
conclusion sentences
and grade their own work
you can customize your worksheet to fit
whatever concept you're covering at that
part of the school year and you can also
have students trade with each other and
grade each other's papers
both options require some setup and
structure put in place first but it's a
wonderful way to help students learn
what mistakes they're making in their
writing without having you just tell
them what they're doing wrong
second i heard this on another podcast
but i think it's a great piece of advice
your district probably only requires a
certain number of grades per semester or
per quarter most teachers actually give
out more grades than they have to
so look into the requirements for your
district and district and talk to the
administration at your school about how
many numerical grades you need to give
out and see if what you're doing is more
than is required
teaching can be really rewarding work
but it is a lot of work i want to
encourage tasha to look up new methods
of teaching and talk to other teachers
about how they manage the workload it
can get better
hi my name is cassidy i live in saint
pete florida i was just listening to the
podcast about impulses and i was
listening to erica talk about her small
business and how she gets stressed out
kind of over other people's consumerism
and
i was just thinking like you know for
the example she gave about the lady
buying more yarn when she already had so
much if that's something that stresses
her out she can maybe try doing like
workshops or offer some sort of
incentives i don't know what else she
sells but maybe
have some sort of event where people
bring in their old yarn and there's some
sort of crafts where she can educate or
how to utilize what people already have
or maybe something like an incentive
where people come in bring their
access that they're not using and that
can be
given a discount towards the people
purchasing something else
and then utilize that those items for
maybe some sort of event that helps
people in the community whether it's a
free event or something for children or
senior citizens something where you can
give back and that way those materials
are being used again that aren't being
used by the people who already have them
and then people are also kind of
reallocating their resources um that
they're not utilizing in their own home
and thus minimalizing what they have and
helping others so that was just
something when i was listening to that
that i thought could be really helpful
you know if she's very passionate and
loves her um business that she has going
on so that way it's not like i have to
give up and try something all new and
start all over and potentially have the
same problems all over again this might
be a solution to
where it causes less stress for her for
erica and her business and then she's
also kind of providing to her clientele
as well as her community
all right y'all big thanks to mel
robbins for joining us today check out
her new book it's called the high five
habit and then of course she's doing
something she has over a hundred
thousand people ryan doing the high five
challenge right now yeah it's a free app
that you can download
hi5challenge.com we'll put a link to
that and the book in the show notes and
then this thursday on patreon we're
gonna spend a ton of time with her
diving deep into the five second rule
and a bunch of other surprise questions
you can join us at patreon.com
the minimalist that's the minimalist
private podcast it's completely separate
from this but it plays in your favorite
podcast app now real quick for right
here right now here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalist
we've been talking about doubts today
and bex and i you know bex has a podcast
called how to love and we just did an
episode over there ryan that is
i mean we talked about all of the doubts
in our marriage especially stuff that's
been coming up recently since we've been
going through this
custody battle in court and it has been
i've talked to you privately about it
and we've finally started talking about
it publicly and semi-publicly if you
want to listen to any of that we have a
public version on apple and spotify and
google or wherever you listen to
podcasts called how to love or if you
want the private version you can find
that at howtolove.show
now ryan for our added value segment
this week we were listening to this
morning
noah gunderson
he's got a brand new album coming out
get out in fact it's out by the time
this episode comes nice and he's got
this song called sleepless in seattle
and it's sort of about falling out of
love with the city that you fell in love
with
and i mean we've all experienced
something like that at some point where
we've been in love in a relationship or
with a job or with somewhere we've been
and then
the self-doubt creeps in or the doubt
about the situation creeps in so this
new album is called a pillar of salt and
this is the lead single from that album
it's called sleepless in seattle by the
way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week
like
how do you move past childhood trauma
and learn to love yourself how do you
strike a balance between loving and
accepting yourself for who you are but
also striving to better yourself
how can you help and interact with
people who speak negatively about
themselves plus a million more questions
for mel
and the minimalist and if you want to
hear all that join us on the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events monthly ask
the minimalist anything sessions and our
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers just like you
subscribe today patreon.com
the minimalists you could follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists come to one
of our live podcast shows we're doing
well we're halfway through the tour
right now ryan the minimalists.com
tour to find a love people use things
tour stop near you you can also sign up
for our email list over there and we'll
notify you when we're coming to a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you leave
here today with just one message let it
be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
bye